Britney Spears celebrates Madonna's  birthday releases new music and Colton  Haynes is in the building  here's what's going on in Britney's  world it's that Britney Spears brand-new  song do you want to come over offer  upcoming album glory we have no doubt  hold hands as already jamming out to the  new single the actor danced on stage a  previous Vegas show last night  reliving the moment on Twitter writing I  don't even know what just happened just  before the show began Britney was  warming up to some classic Madonna for  Lady majus bday  but you go way back remember they  collaborated on a song in 2003 and oh  yeah there was that infamous kiss